which interview was the most surprising
to you I mean I have many favorites of
the ones that I saw but which one really
blew you away in terms of what was said
the the mindset well I think the NRA
gentleman Kyle is the one that you know
still gets me and and seems to have an
effect on other people because there we
are outside a gun show with a guy big
you know with his gun on his side and
his NRA hat on and everything and you
thinking oh god here we go the gun show
thing you know and this guy was amazing
he was an environmentalist one of his
lines is yeah you don't need a sling led
down a range to get your point across
sit down buckle up have a coffee you
know what do politicians really know
about places are trying to take over and
affect in the world you know be a bit
more open to cut other cultures and you
know it was like some lefty tree-hugging
liberal sitting there but he wasn't
necessarily one or the other he was just
present and just thinking well why do we
do this and you don't need to sling let
down arrange it so and it wasn't
necessary that he was one thing or
another to be labeled he was just this
guy just making sense and and just being
kind of logical I guess and but you know
exposed the way that we approach those
situations we go here we go NRA gun show
but then this guy go well no if you got
Sun and solar and you can use the sun's
energy to kind of bring some light for
the night then that kind of makes sense
doesn't it just use the daytime solar
bit to look after the night bit anyway
yeah I guess that makes it then you
don't have to go and trounce around and
do the oil stuff in the kind of places
that we shouldn't really be in and
that's just what he was saying and it
seemed to make sense what he was saying
you know so he would he was just you
know he was fascinating
you